All right.
Quick introduction.
My name is Trevor Norris.
I now work at the NodeSource.
Previously worked at Mozilla,
and then before that,
worked with companies.
I did a lot of front-end.
I worked on doing a lot of
enterprise-level front-end.
My first language
was JavaScript.
My only language was JavaScript
for about six years, honestly,
until I became a Node core
maintainer, at which time,
I was forced to learn C++.
And ever since then, I just
started moving down the stack.
Currently, I'm learning
C, and aspiring
to become one of the libuv
maintainers, as well.
So I'm just going completely
the opposite direction,
which is really odd.
But I do have to say that
coming from client side
and going to server side, and
then going all the way down
to systems-level development
has given me a really, I'd
say, unique insight
into how things work.
Tonight, my talk is
going to be about dealing
with a lot of requests.
Let's just get kicking.
So I did a very
unscientific analysis
of just going to a bunch--
I just went to-- what is it,
Alexis?
I just went to the top
100 or something websites,
and just viewed how many
calls were required just
to load the homepage.
And the majority of them
were 50 or more requests just
for the homepage.
I remember a time
where this would
have been insane or
ridiculous, and people
would have never allowed for it.
But it's very common now.
And it's a new way of
dealing with things.
It's a new way of looking about
how we write our applications.
Now, as it says
here, many of those
are static content, images,
JavaScript, and CSS.
I'll get to why I
air-quoted those later.
But a lot of that is
static, but also, there's
a good amount of
dynamically-generated content.
And that is where
Node is sitting today,
at that level where your
dynamically-generated content
is being processed and
delivered through Node.
Whether it's doing a
back-end call and delivering
JSON down to the client, so that
the client can render the DOM
on the fly, or
whether templates are
being generated on
the server, and being
delivered to the client.
So here are several of
the most popular pages.
And that number is
the number of requests
just to load the home page.
And then, I broke it up into a
number of HTML, and JavaScript,
and CSS files, specifically
for each of those.
And I'll get into later why
those three are important.
The rest of them are
images and whatnot.
But as you can see,
that's borderline insane.
I mean, I'm sorry.
Over 250 individual requests
just to visit the home page?
That's a lot.
I have a really fast connection,
but-- fortunately, amazon.com
has a mobile site, so
they don't do that.
But a lot of people don't.
And so when you're
doing crap like this,
and then you want mobile users
to try and use your website,
you're crap out of luck.
That's just not going to work.
So common uses for
Node I've seen today
are for template generation,
REST APIs, static content
concatenation, and
metrics reporting.
The reason I place the template
generation and the REST
APIs separately
instead of together
is-- excuse me-- is because the
template generation will make
your application CPU-bound,
where REST APIs generally make
calls out to other resources.
And so your application
then becomes
bound by whatever external
resource you're calling to.
A lot of times, it'll make
a call out to a resource,
perhaps in JSON.
This is usually the case
where you're sending JSON down
to the client, where the
client will dynamically
render the DOM.
But template generation
will make your application
completely CPU-bound,
which is to be honest,
I think the oddball
case for Node,
because Node is touted as
being very friendly to I/O.
But template generation
is an important thing.
Its use, as I've seen it,
has increased in popularity
in generating
templates to generate
the actual HTML for the page.
Static content concatenation.
We'll get more into that later.
And then, metrics reporting.
This one is interesting,
because say, for example,
you wanted to keep track of
how well the ping backed.
If you want live metrics
on how many people
are visiting a specific page.
So that means however
many connections you have,
you know that you will be
getting that number of requests
per five seconds or
10 seconds at minimum,
just for the pingback,
plus any additionals.
I know there are some that keep
a ridiculous number of metrics
on everything that's
going on on the page,
and it's constantly making
requests back to the server.
And this can put a lot
of load on your servers.
Part of the reason
for this talk is
to instruct how to get
around these things.
A few common problems
I'd like to point out
are Node applications are
becoming more CPU-bound
as more temple
generation is happening.
So the number of requests
expected are dropping.
Excuse me.
People delivering static
content through Node,
which is just crazy.
Don't deliver static
content through Node.
You have CDNs.
You have a huge number
of other resources
to deliver your truly,
truly static content.
Don't use Node.
Make sure it's filtered out.
One very common one I see
is when the browser hits
the service, and then
it makes the request.
But then, straight up, it
makes a Fave icon request.
Now, the HTTP parser
in Node is not cheap.
We're going to improve that.
But currently, as
it was designed
and for backwards
compatibility, we
haven't been able to
make as many improvements
as we've liked.
And it is not cheap.
And so that one extra
request-- imagine every request
automatically generating
one more request,
just to have it immediately
dumped is just a waste of CPU.
Make sure those things
are filtered out.
Now, external API calls
being a bottleneck.
Well, then you know
Node is doing its job.
If Node is sitting there
at 5%, maybe 10% CPU usage,
but you see thousands
of connections
on your application,
then you know
you're OK, because you're
waiting for some other service
to return new information.
And there's nothing you can do
about that at the Node layer.
And then, another thing I see
is people allowing connections
to be received by
a Node process,
until the process falters.
What we should be doing is
doing performance testing,
keeping metrics on our
production systems,
and finding that sweet spot.
Finding the arch of where
that begins to decline,
and don't allow
it to exceed that.
Shoot to maintain that
as best as possible.
So these bullet points we'll hit
in more detail, so we'll just
address them quickly.
So don't immediately
write small packets.
Reduce the number of
requests in total.
As you saw, there are a
ridiculous number of requests.
For the ones like
images and whatnot,
that's not such a big thing.
Not a lot, in my mind,
we can do about that.
But as far as the numbers you
saw for the JavaScript, CSS,
and HTML, there is a solution
for those that we can address.
And then, also
remember that Node
doesn't gzip your
content by default.
So a lot of times, you're
streaming out content,
and you're forgetting that
your rendered template is
50 to 100 kilobytes,
but you totally
didn't set your gzip encoding,
and actually gzip your data.
Node doesn't do
that automatically.
So you need to
remember to do that
within your own applications.
All right.
So hitting the first bullet
point, don't immediately write.
I've seen some type of modules.
And honestly, the more
popular ones default to what's
called "streaming mode,"
where every time a segment
of template is
generated, it calls
res.write for that segment.
But instead, what
you should be doing
is aggregating the results, and
sending them out all at once
in a single request.
This has two advantages.
One is it allows you to set
the Content-Length header,
and that is important.
As a general rule
of thumb in Node,
if you don't set the
Content-Length header,
you will get approximately
50% fewer requests per second
then if you are to set
the Content-Length.
If you can set the
Content-Length,
you will do much better,
in terms of performance.
Now, some people
might say, well,
I want to get data out
as quickly as possible.
Truth be told, that's
actually not the case.
If you're streaming out lots
of small requests, what's
happening is you're
incurring assist call time,
and you're incurring
a-- excuse me--
you're incurring
garbage collection time.
There are lots of
small things that
accumulate with lots
of small writes.
And hopefully, your
template generation
isn't lasting more
than 10 milliseconds.
If it takes you more
than 10 milliseconds
to do whatever synchronous
operation you need to do,
you need to rethink your
design, because that's not
something Node should be
doing, in my honest opinion.
And so waiting 10
milliseconds for sending out
the beginning of the content
with the end of the content
should not be an issue.
So a note about 0.12, which we
currently have a branch for.
Right now, it's pretty
much in feature freeze,
and we are working
on fixing bugs.
Now that native V8
Promises are in,
there are some bugs around that,
and other things that we're
finishing up to
make sure that it's
usable and fully
working and stable.
But one feature that was added,
which I believe is important,
is that in 0,10, every time
you call Socket.write, or just
resp.write, in terms of the HTTP
module, that makes a syscall.
But coming up with TCP is the
ability to call the cork API.
And the cork API uses what's
called the write.VSS call.
And what happens is when
you cork, it will then halt.
You can call write as
many times as you want,
but internally, it will
aggregate all those.
And then, when you
either call uncork
or you end-- like at the end of
an HTTP call, you call res.end,
it will send all the data down,
and make one single syscall
to the kernel, and say,
read all of these out as one
giant buffer.
The write syscall,
you have to write out
each individual buffer.
But with this new API, you
can treat many buffers as one.
We've seen very high
throughput increases
in writing out small requests,
because of this new ability.
And it will be enabled by
default for the HTTP module
in 0.12.
I need to clarify that, and say
by enabled by default means,
when you start
writing HTTP data,
it automatically
corks at the beginning
of the synchronous code.
And then, it will allow you to
call res.write as many times
as you want.
And then at the end,
it will automatically
uncork it for you, if you
haven't called res.end.
Or if you have called
res.end, it will be sent down.
So in 0.12, if you write
out something immediately,
it won't be sent
out immediately.
It will be sent out when
your synchronous code
execution is complete.
Again, hopefully, your
synchronous code execution
isn't taking more
than 10 milliseconds.
But yeah, that will
be enabled by default
on 0.12 for the HTTP module.
I believe it only
works on Linux,
but since the
majority of servers
we've seen run on
Linux, we figured
that would be a big gain.
Now, there's an idea of
a well-formatted request.
And that is, when you
have an internal API,
you have your own
JavaScript libraries
that you are programming, and it
is making a call to the server.
The format of the request
should be well-formed.
It should have a
very specific format.
Your REST APIs, requesting
content, all of these things
should have a very specific
set of headers or a specific
get request.
And with these, you can
actually bypass the HTTP module
entirely.
We'll show some code
here in a second.
But what you can actually
do is open up a TCP socket,
and then allow HTTP connections
to be made to that TCP socket,
manually extract the data you're
expecting from that API call,
and make the response
as quick as possible.
Say for example, you're
doing a restful API,
and the only portion of the
message you need to know
is the get request.
But say for whatever
reason, there
are a large number of
cookies or something.
There are a large
number of headers
that will require to be parsed.
You can bypass that entire
segment by doing that manually.
Now, this is on the
more advanced level.
This is on the high
performance level,
but that's generally what I do.
To be honest, I get a lot
of people that come up to me
and say, our application's
just fast enough.
We'll talk more about that
later, but I don't-- to me,
there is no fast enough.
I measure performance
degradation
in nanoseconds and clock cycles.
I dump out the assembly code of
the JavaScript that I create.
That's my level of performance.
I know that isn't the
performance of 99.99% of Node
developers out there,
but that's where I live,
and so that's what
I like to share.
So here's an example.
So we're just creating a server,
and we're listening on a port.
On connection, first
thing I'm doing here
is setting Node delay to
disable the-- I believe
you pronounce that
Nagle algorithm.
Now as a quick reminder of what
the Nagle algorithm actually
is, when you make a TCP
request, those packets
are broken up into
sizes, your MTU,
which is usually
around 1,500 bytes.
Now, the Nagle algorithm
says, don't send out
that small packet until
the MTU is either full,
or 200 milliseconds
have passed by.
And so if you're
writing out data,
and the very end
of your response
only takes half
the size of an MTU,
and you haven't disabled
the Nagle algorithm,
it will wait 200 milliseconds
before sending that out.
Also, in this code, I'm
making the assumption
that we're going
to set keepalive,
that this is a web page.
Now, if this was a
restful API, where
people make one-shot
requests, then I
wouldn't be setting keepalive.
Instead, I would be expecting
for them to make a connection,
make a request, and
then end the connection.
So that really depends
on what you're doing.
Now, here you can
see that I'm setting
the three callbacks
for data error.
And now, it does
actually work this way,
where I can hoist
the functions out.
This is a performance thing.
I can hoist the functions out.
Now on data, when you
get the chunk of data
that will contain the raw
headers and body exactly as
sent by the client,
and here's where
you're going to do your
parsing of the raw data.
Now remember, in Node that
the "this" of these functions
is the actual connection
object instance.
So as we'll see, you can just
call this.write, this.end
within those hoisted functions,
and it'll work just fine.
You don't need to embed them
in the on-connection callback,
so that you can reference the C
variable there in on-connection
Now on-air, those are
important to handle.
There are a lot of things that
happen, like handling econ
reset, where in the middle
of a connection response,
the connection just hard
closes on the other end.
That will throw an error.
Those need to be handled.
And then on end, make sure you
clean up all your resources
and close down
your site, or else
you're just going to
have an open socket,
and you're wasting
your resources.
Now, here's a small graph.
This is a single
Node instance running
on a 512-megabyte
digital ocean droplet.
So it's pretty
low-powered, but I
tried to simulate
as close as I could
real-world throughput
on a restful API call.
And as we can see,
at the beginning,
they're pretty much the same.
But the bottom there, you
have simultaneous requests.
And as you can see, when
you get over 200, 250,
you're pushing around 800
additional requests per second
by manually parsing
those yourself.
x
Now, for high-traffic
websites, that
can mean two, three,
four less servers.
And those servers
can cost a lot.
So a matter of savings and
making me happy, because I
know that you have
made your application
as fast as possible.
So also, there's this idea of
reducing the number of requests
by concatenating sets
of dynamic content.
You can do that by
basically creating
a hashmap of segmented
pieces of data.
Like for example,
we saw earlier,
there were 17, 20 JavaScript
files, and 10 CSS files.
Those could technically be
concatenated, and be sent down
to the client in one request.
So here is a very basic example,
just get the point across,
of using this idea
of concatenating
sets of static content, as
requested by the client,
on the fly.
Basically, when your
application starts up,
you read in all the files
from your resource directory.
And say, for each
template you have,
you have a specific CSS
file and/or JavaScript file.
And so you can read those in.
And remember, those will be
read in as a Node buffer,
and buffers lives
outside of the V8 heap.
So if you have a machine
that has plenty of memory,
you can go as high as you want.
It's really not an issue.
Now, the on data, this is
from the TCP sock example.
First thing we're going
to do is use the cork API
that's going to be
coming out in 0.12.
And then, say where that second
comment is, basically, we
do some quick parsing.
We make an API call, we figure
out what resources are needed,
and then, we just loop
through and do a write
on all the segments of content.
And then, we do an
end at the very end,
so they're all written out
as if they were one big file.
And so each request
could technically
have a unique set of
pieces of static data,
but they're written out
as a single large file
to the client.
And if you hook up a
CDN in front of that,
your performance will
drastically increase,
instead of trying to either
push down the full 1.5-megabyte
JavaScript file that
contains all the JavaScript
for your entire site, or
returning 17 JavaScript files
individually.
Now, addressing the fact
there's no default compression,
here's a very simple example.
So we're going to say that
the object variable is a JSON
object from a restful
API call that we
made to some other service.
We're going to go ahead
and gzip that sucker.
We're going to set the
proper headings or headers,
and then, we're going to
send that out over the pipe.
That will allow us
to properly compress
our content before
sending it down.
In my test, I was showing
around 50% decrease in size.
But unfortunately, it
does have quite a big hit.
So I just ran this for 250
simultaneous connections
at approximately one
kilobyte response.
I made it very
small in response,
because I was more interested
in the CPU hit overall.
And so when I gzipped
it, I was only
getting 980 requests
per second on average.
And when I just did it
plain text streaming,
I got about 1400.
So to be honest, probably the
most performant way to do this
is to use an external method
of gzipping your data.
A lot of times, you'll have
a CDN or something in front,
or any resource in
front, that can just
gzip that data as
it's going out.
Node is good.
This is one area
where it alters,
in terms of what other
libraries can do.
And I would say, take
advantage of that.
Get that data compressed
as it's going out.
And final thoughts.
I've addressed a
very few things that
can be done to optimize
your applications.
Node has many ways
that I haven't
addressed that can be optimized.
And I never want "it's fast
enough to get in your way."
Yes, making sure it works
properly, that your tests pass,
that it's stable,
those are important.
But saying, "well,
it's fast enough,"
is like saying, "well, I
don't want my site to grow."
Because yes, I can
handle all the requests
that I want right now.
But then, say suddenly,
you're running
a site that gets put on
a reddit or a slashdot.
Plenty of websites
have been slashdotted,
where it's up one second
and down 10 minutes later,
because it gets a huge
flurry of requests.
And then, my last thing would
be, while programming in Node,
be creative.
Many of my best optimizations,
especially in Node core
have began with even
the Node core team
saying, that's not possible.
You're insane.
There's no way that can work.
And then, I go off in my own
little corner for a few days,
and I fram it out, and
then show everybody and be,
no, actually it will work.
We can do this, and it's
reliable and stable.
It just took a
little creativity.
But be creative with Node.
JavaScript is a fun language.
You can do things in a
lot of different ways.
And that will allow you
to figure out not only
your most comfortable
way of doing things,
but also figure out new ways of
doing things, things that you
might not be comfortable
with, but yet are
fun and exciting and different.
So thank you very much.
I hope that some of this
was helpful to some of you.